بعد حديث بوتين عن نقل قنابل نوويه
تكتيكيه الى بيلاروسيا واشنطن لا ترى سببا
لتعديل موقفها النووي
اكمال مسوده الاتفاق السياسي النهائي
حريه وتغيير تعلن اكتمال المسوده النهائيه
للاتفاق السياسي بالسودان وتسليمها لقوى
الايطاليه اليوم
في اول تجمع انتخابيه منذ اعلانه ترشح
رسميا للانتخابات
يرفض تحقيق القضائي ضده
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا بكم معنا
الى هذه النشره المفصله تاتيكم من العربيه
قالت وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه انه لا توجد
مؤشرات الى ان روسيا تستعد لاستخدام اسلحه
نوويه وانها لم ترى اي سبب لتعديل وضعها
النووي الاستراتيجي الموقف الامريكي جاء
بعد اعلان الرئيس الروسي عن نشر اسلحه
نوويه تكتيكيه في روسيا البيضاء واضاف
بوتين ان بلاده وارسلت عشر مقاتلات
لديها القدره على حمل اسلحه نوويه الى
بيلاروسيا واوضح بوتين ان ارسال اسلحه
نوويه الى بيلاروسيا لن ينتهك المعاهدات
الدوليه او اتفاقيات عدم انتشار الاسلحه
النوويه وشرفوا الى ان بلاده لا تنقل
اسلحتها النوويه الى بيلاروسيا بل تعيد
تموضعها كما فعلت امريكا في اوروبا وفق
قوله
لا نعطي بيلاروسيا اسلحه نوويه بل ببساطه
ننقل اسلحتنا الى هناك مثل ما تفعل
الولايات المتحده منذ عقود لقد سلمنا
بالفعل لا بيلاروسيا منظومه اسكندر
المعروفه والفعاله للغايه في الثالث من
ابريل سنبدا تدريب الطاقه وفي الاول من
يوليو سننتهي من بناء منشاه تخزين خاصه
للاسلحه النوويه التكتيكيه على اراضي
بيلاروسيا
اعلن بوتين او اعلان بوتا ياتي بعد تاكيد
رئيس الاركان الاوكراني
ان قوتي بلاده تمكنت من تحقيق الاستقرار
في مدينه والتي شهدت اعنف المعارك منذ
اندلاع الحرب وقال زولوجي على حسابه في
فيسبوك قال ان تحقيق الاستقرار جاء بفضل
جهود القوه الاوكرانيه ومن جهه اكدت وزاره
الدفاع البريطانيه في بيان لها انه من
المرجح ان يكون التفوق الاوكراني في
المنطقه جاء نتيجه لاستنزاف الشديد للقوات
الروسيه والتي تتكبد خسائر بشريه فادحه
حسب ما اورده البيان البريطاني
اكد المتحدث الرسمي باسم المجلس المركزي
للقوى الحريه وتغيير جعفر حسن الانتهاء من
صياغه المسوده النهائيه للاتفاق السياسي
وقال في مؤتمر صحفي ان مسوده الاتفاق
السياسي اكتملت نهائيا وستسلم اليوم
للموقعين عند التاسعه مساء مشيرا الى ان
الحريه والتغيير تلتزم او ستلتزم
بالمواقيت النهائيه للعمليه السياسيه التي
ستنتهي بتشكيل الحكومه في الحادي عشر من
ابريل المقبل
ثم اكمال مسوده الاتفاق السياسي النهائي
وستسلم يوم غد
لكل
الموقعين سواء كانوا مدنيين او عسكريين
عند التاسعه مساء بالقصر الجمهوري سيتم
تسليم المسوده لكل طرف حتى يكون بشكل
نهائي كله طرف ابدا موافقه النهائيه لان
اللجنه ظلت تعمل ليله نهار بواقع جلستين
في اليوم لاكمال هذه المسوده حتى نلتزم
بالمواقيت التي ضربناها في تواريخها واحد
ابريل وسته ابريل و 11 ابريل لكي تقوم
مواقيت نهائيه كما امن المجلس على
التاكيد على هذه المواقيت والالتزام بها
وهذا لزم من اللجنه ان تستمر ليلا نهار
لعقد هذا الامر يوم غد ايضا عند العاشره
صباحا ستعقد ورشه الاصلاح الامني والعسكري
بمشاركه الاجهزه النظاميه ومشاركه
المدنيين ومعاشي القوات النظاميه في لقاء
له ما بعده في عمليه الاصلاح الامني
والعسكري للوصول لمؤسسات تخدم الدوله
المدنيه القادمه وتعتقدم التحول المدني
الديمقراطي وهذا سيكون من مصلحه هذا الشعب
العظيم ان يكون له جيش موحد قوي وان يتم
الاصلاح الامني والعسكري في هذا الاطار
في المقابل جددت الكتله الديمقراطيه رفضها
للعمليه السياسيه وقال الناطق باسمها محمد
زكريا في مقابله مع العربيه قال ان تشكيل
حكومه المعارضه موازيه وارد بالنسبه لي
الحريه واللا تغيير الكتله الديمقراطيه
ولن تكون هذه الحكومه قصرا على الكتله
اللا ديمقراطيه وانما ايضا ما يجري من
عمليه سياسيه وجدت الرفض عريض من قوى
الثوريه حيه من على سبيل المثال منها حزب
البعث الحزب العشوائي هناك التيار الجزري
هناك قوى لجان لمقاومه سنعمل على ان نلتقي
مع هذه اللاقوه على ارضيه مشتركه اتناقش
هموم الوطن ونؤسس لحكومه على الاقل بقاعده
عريضه اليست حكومه اقليه هذا واحد من
الخيارات ولكن دعيني اؤكد اننا لا دلنا
نقول ان ابوابنا مفتوحه للحوار
اكد مصدر عسكري للعربيه وصول رئيس الاركان
العامه التابع للجيش الليبي عبد الرزاق
الناظوري الى طرابلس واضاف المصدر ان
ناظوري وصل الى طرابلس رفقه اعضاء لجنه
خمسه زائد خمسه لاستكمال المباحثات التي
جرت في تونس الايام الماضيه برعايه الامم
المتحده ومن اهم الملفات التي ستناقش في
الاجتماع والذي يلقى الدعم من امريكيا
كبيرا انشاء قوه مشتركه بين الشرق والغرب
والجنوب وتامين اجراءات الانتخابات
اعلنا المبعوث الامريكي الخاص ليبيا
امريكيه جديده لعشر سنوات في ليبيا لمنع
الصراع ودعم الانتخابات وذلك وفقا لحساب
السفاره الامريكيه لدى ليبيا على تويتر
قال نورلاند ان استراتيجيه واشنطن تعتمد
على شركات بناءه وعلى برامج على مستوى
المجتمع لدعم تطلعات الشعب الليبي لتحقيق
الاستقرار والمساءله والحوكمه كما اشار
المبعوث الامريكي لدى ليبيا الى ان هذه
المبادرات تؤكد التزام الولايات المتحده
بالوقوف الى جانب الشعب الليبي ودعم
التقدم نحو حكومه موحده منتخب ديمقراطيا
يمكنها تقديم الخدمات العامه وتعزيز النمو
الاقتصادي في جميع المجالات
ادعمت منظمه اس او
اسرينيا الاوروبيه غير الحكوميه خفر
السواحل الليبيه بتعريض طاقم سفينتها اوشن
فايكنج ومهاجرين على متن قارب للخطر بشكل
متعمد وذلك خلال تنفيذ عمليات انقاذ وقالت
المنظمه الانسانيه التي تتخذ من مدينه
مارسيليا الفرنسيه مقرا لها قالت ان جميع
محاولات الاتصال بمقل مقر خفر السواحل
الليبي باءت بالفشل في وقت بدا فيه خفر
السواحل الليبيه التصرف بشكل عدائي على حد
تعبير المنظمه مهددا بالسلاح ومطلقا عده
عيره في الهواء تجاه السفينه ووفقا
للمنظمات تم في النهايه اعتراض نحو 80
شخصا من قبل خفر السواحل الليبي وتمت
اعادتهم الى ليبيا
في ملف الهجره ايضا لاقيه 19 مهاجرا على
الاقل من دول افريقيه جنوب الصحراء لقوا
حتفهم عندما غرق قاربهم او قريبهم قباله
تونس اثناء محاولاتهم عبور البحر المتوسط
الى ايطاليا بحسب ما افادت منظمه حقوقيه
تونسيه وخلال الايام الاربعه الماضيه
غريقه خمسه قوارب للمهاجرين قباله مدينه
صفاقس الجنوبيه مما اسفر عن وفاه تسعه
وفقدان 67 وذلك بعد زياره او زياده كبيره
في عدد القوارب المتجهه نحو ايطاليا
قال الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن في رساله
لكونجريس ان ضربات الامريكيه الاخيره في
سوريا كانت موجهه لمنشات تستخدمها جماعات
تابعه للحرس الثوري الايراني في القياده
والسيطره وتخزين الذخائر واوضح بعضنا ان
القوه الامريكيه استهدفت منشات في شرق
سوريا ردا على الهجمات الاخيره وتعهدات
المستمره بشن هجمات في المستقبل مشيرا الى
انه امر بتوجيه الضربات الخميس الماضي من
اجل الحمايه والدفاع عن سلامه الافراد
الامريكيين واضعاف ولتعطي لسلسله الهجمات
المستمره ضد الولايات المتحده
وشركائها واكد بايدن ان قرار شن الضربات
الاخيره في سوريا كان ضروريا ويتناسب بما
يتفق مع القانون الدولي ضمن ممارسه
الولايات المتحده لحقها في الدفاع عن
النفس وان الضربات الامريكيه الاخيره في
سوريا جاءت بهدف الرضع
وراعه تجنب وقوع ضحايا بين صفوف المدنيين
في اول تجمع انتخابيا له منذ اعلانه رسميا
ترشح الانتخابات الرئاسه المقرره عام 2004
رفض الرئيس الامريكي السابق تحقيق
القضائيه الجاري حول معتبرا بانه اداه
لاستهداف الخصوم السياسيين وقالت ترامبلي
انصاره في واكو بولايه تكساس قال ان
المدعي العام لينيورك يحقق معه بتوجيه
بتوجيه مما سماها بوزاره الظلم في واشنطن
كان المدعي العام لمقاطعه نيويورك تحت
رعايه وتوجيه وزاره الظلم في واشنطن
العاصمه يحقق معي في شيء ليس بجريمه وليس
جنحه وليس قضيه اخلاقيه
اتهمه خلفه جو بايدن بسوء استخدام السلطه
قائلا ان الفساد مستشرا في كافه المستويات
الحكوميه وانا الولايات المتحده تبدو الان
كجمهوريه من دول العالم الثالث
سوء استخدام السلطه موجود في كافه مستويات
الحكومه هناك فساد مستشرم في كل مكان هذا
يحدث امام اعيننا لكننا سنفوز ان استخدام
نظام بايدن لاجهزته في انفاذ القانون يرقى
لما قام به ستالين في السابق ويبدو ان هذا
بدا منذ بدايه الشيوعيه ونحن نبدو وكاننا
جمهوريه من جمهوريات العالم الثالث
جمهوريه الموز مع تزوير الانتخابات اضحينا
جمهوريه الموز ان العداله يجب ان تتحقق
نحن سوف ندافع عن ذلك عندما تنتهي تلك
الانتخابات وساكون رئيسا للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه قرار اسرائيل
بنشر عطاءات لبناء وحدات استيطانيه داخل
الاراضي الفلسطينيه اكدت الخارجيه
السعوديه ان قرار اسرائيل يعد استمرارا
للانتهاكات الصارخه من جانب سلطتها
واكدت الرياض على ضروره اطلاع المجتمع
الدولي بمسؤولياته لانها الاحتلال او
لانهاء الاحتلال ووقف ممارسته الاستفزازيه
هذا وكانت الخارجيه الاردنيه ادانا الطرحه
اسرائيل عطاءات لبناء اكثر من الف وحده
استيطانيه في الاراضي الفلسطينيه مؤكده ان
تلك النشاطات الاستيطانيه تعد خرقا فاضحا
للقانون الدولي وتقويضا لاسس السلام ووجود
تحقيقه وجهود تحقيقه وفرص حل الدولتين كما
شددت الخارجيه الاردنيه على ان الممارسات
الاحاديه التي تقوم بها اسرائيل غير شرعيه
ولا قانونيه وهي مرفوضه ومدامه
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
اشتباكات بين انصار اللكود والمحتاجين ضد
التعديلات القضائيه في اسرائيل ووزير
الدفاع يحذر من خطر داهم
اهلا بكم من جديد في اسرائيل اندلعت
مواجهات بين متظاهرين والمئات من انصار
الليكود الذين وصلوا الى شارع كابلان في
تل ابيب
ورددوا هتافات ضد المحتجين في شوارع ومدن
اسرائيل بسبب رفضهم لخطه تغيير نظام
القضائي ما دفع بالشرطه الى التدخل
ومحاوله فض المواجهات من خلال استخدامه
خراطيم المياه
هذا وتحدث وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
حول ازمه تعديلات القضائيه ودعا جالانت
الى تعليق التعديلات في الوقت الحالي
وايضا الى وقف التظاهرات وقال ان اسرائيل
تواجه تحديات امنيه غير مسبوقه مشيرا الى
ان عمق الانقسام الداخلي حول تعديل نظام
القضائي هو خطر داهم على انه اسرائيل
من اجل امن اسرائيل من اجل ابنائنا
وبناتنا يجب ايقاف العمليه التشريعيه في
هذا الوقت السماح لشعب اسرائيل بالاحتفال
بعيد الفصح وعيد الاستقلال معا
ولنحزن معا في يوم الذكرى ويوم الهولوكوست
هذه ايام مقدسه بالنسبه لنا
نحن بحاجه الى وقف المظاهرات والاحتجاجات
والتواصل من اجل الحوار اي مظهر من مظاهر
التردد الذي ينال من قوه جيش الدفاع
الاسرائيلي ويضر بالنظام الامني يجب ان
يتوقف على الفور من اجل امننا ومن اجل
وحدتنا من واجبنا العوده الى ساحه الحوار
قبل بضعه اسابيع من الانتخابات الرئاسيه
التركيه اعلن محرم ان جاء احد ابرز الوجوه
المعارضه عن ترشحه منفردا امرنا اعتبره
محللون ضربه لتحالف المعارضه وقد ينقل
الانتخابات الى جوله ثانيه لن تفيد
المعارضه بقدر افادتها للرئيس الحالي رجب
طيب اردوغان بينما توحد المعارضه التركيه
قواها لمواجهه رئيس اردوغان في الانتخابات
المقبله هناك من يهدد هذا التحالف ويخلط
اوراقه انه محرم ان جاء ابرز وجوه
المعارضه ورجالها في انتخابات 2018 نفس
اردوغان على الرئاسه لكنه اعترف بخسارته
عبر رساله صحفيه ان جاء وقبل اسابيع عمل
الاستحقاق الدستوري اعلن ترشحه منفردا تحت
الوان حزبه الوطن ترشح الخطيب المثير
للجدل اعتبر نبا غير صار للمعارضه
فمحرم ان لديه قدره على جذب اصوات نخب
بحزبي الشعب والخير ابرز التشكيلات
المعارضه التركيه
بترشحه ووفقا لمحللين يمكن ان يلعب دور
المفسد ويقود الانتخابات الى جوله ثانيه
هذه الجوله ان لم تضر باردوغان فستفسد
الامر على تحالف المعارضه تحالف يدخل
الصراع بسباق مع الزمان لاقناع محرم انجيء
على الانسحاب
المضحك المبكي ان يشعل التوقيت الصيفي في
لبنان حربا افتراضيه وتحركات اعتراضيه
ويخلق توقيتين في البلاد فبعدما قرر رئيس
البرلمان والحكومه تاجيل العمل بتوقيت
الصيفي حتى نهايه شهر رمضان والذي كان من
المفترض ان يبدا عند منتصف هذه الليله
سادت موجه اعتراضات لعدد كبير من المؤسسات
والصروح الدينيه المسيحيه والمدارس التي
قررت عدم الالتزام بهذا القرار حظ هذا
الامر سبب ضياعا لدى اللبنانيين الذين
انقسموا بين السخريه من هذا الموضوع وبين
الضيق منه
هكذا وبدردشه بينهما قرر رئيس البرلمان
والحكومه تاجيل العمل بالتوقيت الصيفي حتى
نهايه شهر رمضان المبارك قرار رسم مشهدا
استرياليا على الحياه اللبنانيه بردود
الفعل عليه يعني هالقد في بزنس وشغل
بلبنان لحتى الساعه تاثر عليها يعني
نحن صايمين نستفيد منها هيدي الساعه في
لببكه بالايمان
لنشوف شو بدنا نعمل لانه عم نشتغل نحن
كمان مع بره وفي سفر قد يعتبره البعض
موضوعا سخيفا الا انه فتح باب الطائفيه
على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي لتبدا
الاتهامات باسلمت النظام السياسي ليرد
عليها بعدم احترام العيش المشترك فيما
تبقى المشكله الاساسيه فوض القرارات
والتفرد بها وفي حكم ما في الساعه موقفه
من زمان عنا
قررت مؤسسات عده عدم الالتزام بقرار مجلس
الوزراء واعلنت انها ستبدا بالعمل
بالتوقيت الصيفي في وقته الاساسي كشركات
ومطاعم ومدارس ومؤسسات اعلاميه فيما شركه
الطيران الشرق الاوسط اضطرت الى تعديل
مواعيد كل رحلاتها بعد البلبله التي حصلت
اهدى اول شيء اما لا يتعلق بتدبير حكومه
وانما بين رئيسا اثنين ما فينا نلتزم باذر
لانه كل الدراسات العالميه بتشير انه على
الاقل بدك سنه قبل لحتى تبلغي الجهات
المعنيه وخصوصا الجهات المعنيه بالتوقيت
انه هي بلغيها بالاذاب الذي يمكن ان يتخذ
ثم نحن نتضرر كتير من هالامر لانه نحن عنا
ارتباطات بمشاهدين بكل انحاء العالم احدى
العائلات سترسل ابنها مدرسته في التوقيت
الاول وبعدها بساعه سترسل ابنها الاخر الى
مدرسه اخرى بعد ان امتد الخلاف الى
المدارس هي عينه من الضياع الذي سيعيشه
اللبنانيون مع وجود التوقيتين في بلدهم
ففي بلدان العالم هناك توقيت جرينتش اما
في لبنان فتوقيت صيفي او توقيت بري او
توقيت ميقاتي وحتى توقيت اسلامي او مسيحي
لبنان الذي في الاساس اصبح خارج الزمن
بازماته باتت ساعه من هذا الزمن كفيله
باشعاله طائفيا وكان الشعب يعيش حياه
ورديه ستؤثر عليها ساعه مقدمه او مؤخره
ناهد يوسف العربيه بيروت
عربه وزير الخارجيه الصيني عن امله في ان
تتخلل الولايات المتحده عم وصفها
بالاساليب غير المالوفه لاحتواء الصين
وخلال لقاء مع رجال اعمال امريكيين رحب
وزير الخارجيه الصيني بمواصله الشركات
الامريكيه الاستثماراتها في الصين واعرب
عن عمله في ان تعمل واشنطن مع بكين للتغلب
على الصعوبات
فتح الجدال دائر حول تطبيق تيك توك في
الولايات المتحده وغيرها من الدول الغربيه
فتح النقاش حول طبيعه الصراعات
التكنولوجيه المستقبليه والتي من المتوقع
ان تهيمن عليها التطبيقات بشكل كبير
هل الصراع التكنولوجي حول العالم بدا يدخل
منعطفا جديدا فالجدل المثار مؤخرا حول
تطبيق تيك توك الصيني وحمله الحظر التي
تعرض لها في الكثير من البلدان الغربيه
فتح النقاش على الابعاد الحقيقيه وراء هذه
الحمله هذا ما تطرقت اليه صحيفه غوستريت
جورنال الامريكيه التي اعتبرت ان الدول
باتت مدعوه الان الى الالتفات اكثر الى ما
اسمتها دبلوماسيه التطبيقات سباق تفوق في
مجال التطبيقات وجودتها وخصوصا انتشارها
لم يعد يقل اهميه عن اي تفوق تكنولوجي او
صناعي حقيقه دفعت الصين منذ سنوات من
البحث عن الرياضه في البرمجيات وخدمات
الذكاء الاصطناعي كما ان ما تقوم به
الولايات المتحده وبعض الدول الغربيه
اتجاه تيك توك حاليا سلكته الصين منذ زمن
طويل حين حضرت العديد من التطبيقات من
الولايات المتحده ودول اخرى ونجاح تيك توك
ليس الا ثمره مجهودات الصين في هذا الباب
ويتوفر التطبيق حاليا على مليار وثمانمائه
مليون مستخدم في جميع انحاء العالم وذلك
بعد سبع سنوات فقط من انشائه ما يعكس
الفائده التجاريه والسياسيه ايضا التي
تحققها الصين من هذا الانتشار والتي من
شانها ان تقلق منافسيها الاكثر من ذلك هو
ان توجه الصيني الامريكي بحذر تطبيقات
الدول المنافسه سياسيا او اقتصاديا قد
يؤدي الى تقسيم دول العالم الى مجالين
تقنيين احدهما متحالف مع الولايات المتحده
والاخر يحتضن التكنولوجيا الصينيه واذا
كانت تهمه المواجهه لتيك توك هي التجسس
فان الدوره قد ياتي على تطبيقات صينيه
اخرى لكن بتهم مختلفه مثل تطبيقات
لن يقتصر على واشنطن فحسب بل ان هناك
صراعا مشابها سيبرز بين دول مختلفه اما
لخلافات سياسيه او الاعتبارات اقتصاديه
وهو ما ينذر بعهد جديد من الصراع
التكنولوجي عنوانه التطبيقات اسامه الذهبي
العربيه
تبدا نائبه الرئيس الامريكي كامله هاريس
اليوم جوله افريقيه تستهدف الترويج لرؤيه
جديده لواشنطن تعتبر القاره السمراء
مستقبل العالم تاتي الجوله وفق اطار
المساعي الامريكيه المتواصله لتعزيز
وجودها في القاره ومجابهه نفوذ الصيني
والروسيه حيث تشمل جوله هاريس ثلاثه دول
افريقيه هي غانا وتنزانيا وزامبيا وتاتي
زياره نائبه الرئيس الامريكي بعد ايام من
زياره وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه والنيجر
قال وزير الخارجيه المجريه بيتر سيارتو ان
انتقاد الغرب المستمر لبلاده بشان القضايا
الديمقراطيه والثقافيه يجعل الحكومه
اليمنيه متردده في تقديم الدعم في الامور
العمليه وتحديدا حشد النيتو ضد روسيا وفي
مقابله مع الاسوشيات قال وزير الخارجيه
المجاري ان بلاده لم تصوت على السماح
لفنندا والسويد بال السويد بالانضمام الى
النيتولي الى المشرعين المجريين سائموا من
انتقادات تلك الدول لشؤون الداخليه
المجريه مضيفا رفض بلاده في تشكيك
السياسيين الفنلنديين والسويديين في طبيعه
الديمقراطيه لنظام بلاده السياسي
في فرنسا وقعت صدامات بين محتجين وقوات
الامن حول مخزون مياه متنازع عليه قيد
الانشاء في وسط غرب فرنسا حيث احتشد
الالاف على الرغم من حظر التجمع وابرم
نارا في سياره تابعه للشرطه
بمناسبه ساعه الارض اطفات العديد من
المعالم الشهيره حول العالم انوارها
للتوعيه بضروره الحفاظ على الكوكب ساعه
الارض حدثت حدث عالمي يقام في كل عام في
اخر سبت من شهر مارس
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ختام هذه النشره الى العناوين
بعد حديث بوتين عن نقل قنابل نوويه
تكتيكيه الى بيلاروسيا واشنطن لا ترى سببا
لتعديل موقفها النووي
اكمال مسوده الاتفاق السياسي النهائي
الحريه وتغيير تعلن اكتمال المسوده
النهائيه للاتفاق السياسي بالسودان
وتسليمها لقوى الايطاليه اليوم
في اول تجمع الانتخابي منذ اعلانه ترشح
رسميا للانتخابات يرفض التحقيق القضائي يا
ضده
مشاهدينا العربيه من المتابعه عضو القاكم
على راس الساعه في نشره مفصله اخرى الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]